pas mal là
pour ce compte la mère elle est calme
comme ça
on y va super il devait se dire oui mais
le maire de Béziers ah non je vais quand
même pas marier quelqu'un dans l'état me
dit que sa place n'est pas en France
elle est à l'extérieur de la France en
cause le fiancé de 23 ans algérien en
France depuis 7 ans est en situation et
régulière sous le coup d'une auqtf d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français qui expire dans un mois il a
également été condamné pour des faits de
vol et de violence j'ai envie de dire
mais peu importe ce que vous pensiez
c'est écrit dans la Convention
européenne je relis l'article 12 il est
impossible d'interdire à une personne de
se marier sous prétexte de sa religion
de sa couleur de peau de sa situation
aux yeux de l'administration du pays
dans lequel elle vit j'ai fait une
erreur je sais que je fais une erreur
mais me fais passer pour un délinquant
qui qui n'a rien à faire ici en France
et moi j'ai grandi ici j'accepterai pas
qui qui me fasse ça refuser ce matin le
mariage et pourtant autorisé par la
justice selon le procureur de la
République de Béziers l'audition du
couple par les services de la mairie
d'arriver les aucune incohérence et
suspicions de mariage blanc de Robert
Ménard ne sont pas confirmés je trouve
ça dégueulasse mais on est très amoureux
avec ma femme on habite ensemble ça fait
plus que 7 mois
je trouve ça dégueulasse monsieur tant
que ma femme allait avec avec moi je
m'en fous de Ménard et même si je
m'arrerie je me marierai ailleurs même
si si je me marie ailleurs je peux aller
en Algérie mon mari vous inquiétez pas
Madame et je reviendrai en France avec
mes papiers voilà vous venez d'entendre
en direct le marié qui qui s'exprimait
en expliquant qu'il resterait là qu'il
ne bougerait pas qu'il voulait être
marié qu'il trouvait ça dégueulasse
c'est les mots qu'il vient d'employer
dégueulasse qu'on ne Marie pas qui
pouvait aller se marier en Algérie s'il
le voulait donc voilà
non mais il faut y aller dans ce cas-là
enfin puisque en France ça pose problème
faut qu'il aille se marier en Algérie
lui se lèche beaucoup les testicules ou
pas c'est comme d'habitude peut-être il
voudrait bien mais il peut pas
effectivement il y a une asymétrie
testiculaire écoutez vous savez ce qu'on
va faire on va aller faire une
échographie du testicule comme ça je
serais tranquille
il y a moins de 15% des obligations de
quitter le territoire qui sont mises en
œuvre moi
est-ce que je peux
j'avais raison
vous voulez bien que je veux monsieur
en fait et
si vous me donnez raison en silence ce
serait plus sympathique d'une minute
voilà
il clash ok ok les moyens seront massifs
pour protéger les Français pendant ces
deux jours sensibles des 13 et 14
juillet c'est ce que vient de déclarer
Elisabeth borne à nos confrères du
Parisien pour empêcher de nouvelles
violences après celles qui ont suivi la
mort de Naël la première ministre a
annoncé que la vente et le transport de
mortier d'artifice serait notamment
interdit sauf pour les professionnels
organisant des feux d'artifice et pour
comprendre c'est en échangeant avec vous
sur le diagnostic et puis sur les
réponses qu'on doit apporter qu'on
trouvera les bonnes solutions il y a
tout il y a 40 ans de vie politique
là-dedans on a besoin de comprendre en
échangeant avec vous ça sert à rien
évidemment il y a tous en fait il y a
tout ce que sont les Petits Hommes Gris
incapables d'action je vous assure
madame borne pendant la guerre c'est
compliqué a besoin de comprendre il y en
a d'autres qui sont déjà à Londres
attention attention
allez allez on va y aller
il veut pas bouillir son costard
attends il va y aller
c'est pourquoi il existe le débit de
faciès pourquoi c'est ça question qui va
aussi la plupart on l'a dit la plupart
des délinquants sont des noms Kevin et
des non Mathéo donc du coup les bons
papers les mauvais et c'est là où c'est
dangereux on oublie qu'il y a des bons
et c'est ça que c'est important que
c'est important à dire il y a des bons
qui sont des noms Kevin et des noms
Mathéo et qui sont bons et qui aiment la
France et qui travaillent pour la France
la censure l'écusson encore et puis si
ils veulent dire parce qu'il est dedans
parce qu'il y a la
faut vous détendre
aussi dans le dictionnaire vous pouvez
le dire profitez-en dites-le-haut est
fort s'il vous plaît il y avait quoi
comme mot ça fait du bien ça libère un
peu hein j'ai déjà dit moi j'ai des amis
musulmans j'ai des amis qui sont
Africains j'ai des amis qui et qui
aiment la France qui se battent pour la
France et ça il faut le dire et pour le
dire il faut commencer par dire qu'il
n'y avait pas
imaginer des Matteo sur le terrain ça
c'est la réalité il s'avère que nous
avons pu consulter la liste des prénoms
des personnes qui ont été interpellées à
l'an vous a pas mis toute la liste bien
évidemment voilà le top 20 des prénoms
alors il y en a il y en a forcément
beaucoup par ordre alphabétique vous
avez du Adam du Alexis dual et du Bryan
du David du dylanzo du Hugo j'ai pas
tous les faire vous avez du Nassim vous
avez du thé ou vous avez du Yanis bon ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'en fait c'est prénom
ils sont à l'image de la France c'est la
diversité française ils sont à l'image
de notre société la prochaine étape
c'est Thibault de montbrillac qui l'a
dit ce qui changera c'est lorsque ils
entreront dans la maison de Gérard
Leclerc là ça changera
ils seront dans Paris il pilleront dans
Paris et les bobos les intellos tous
ceux qui sont très loin de ces quartiers
dire il faut faire quelque chose là ils
sont chez nous
ils sont entrés dans ma maison
c'est pas bien s'il vient de payer chez
moi ils seront d'abord passés chez vous
bien sûr bon Daniel il est très
ressemblant mais est-ce que c'est bon au
moins on va le goûter vous croyez que il
est d'accord
je pense
[Musique]
il y a une responsabilité des parents
moi mes parents étaient immigrés ma
maman elle avait une raquette en bois je
peux te dire qu'à 17h30 il y avait la
raquette en bois j'étais terrorisé par
cette récente au bois et si je rentrais
pas fermé de voir
et j'ai aujourd'hui cette raquette en
bois je le remercie tous les jours elle
fait quoi faisait quoi
bien sûr
si je voulais traîner dans la rue si je
voulais traîner dans la rue elle me
taper et je devais rentrer pour faire
mes devoirs alors là aujourd'hui je la
remercie la raquette en bois attention
a autant d'immigrés que nous des
immigrés Turs qui n'ont pas les mêmes
problèmes
je ne l'exclut pas où vous comprenez
rien je ne l'explique pas ce qui est pas
gentil de dire ça je donne des arguments
c'est pas un argument vous comprenez pas
ce qu'on vous dit mais non vous ne
comprenez pas vous répondez il y a le
même nombre d'étrangers c'est pas le
problème
je me suis récemment lancée aussi dans
l'escalade de table parce qu'au final
c'est pas si facile que ça est-ce que
vous allez vous mettre le problème c'est
le problème c'est que vous avez des
Français qui ne se sentent pas français
et pourquoi ne se sentent-ils pas
françaises
largement auprès de la faute de
l'urbanisme on en revient largement
question effectivement la couleur de la
salle
sentiment d'appartenance tient à la
taille de votre maison la préfecture du
Val d'Oise interdit la marche prévue
pour les 7 ans de la mort d'Adama Traoré
mort lors d'une interpellation en 2016
Adama Traoré est devenu emblème des
violences policières et cette
interdiction intervient dans le contexte
tendu des émeutes qui ont fait suite au
décès de Naël le comité Adama emmené par
la soeur de la victime compte déposer un
référé pour contester cette interdiction
Jean-François un gendarme de 40 ans
habitué au dépassement de soi et aux
efforts physiques intenses
bonceau pour